to welcome everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good buddy keep the applause going he
says we don't entertain here the best of
us welcome to the H Street podcast when
it's time what is that whoa what are you
guys doing back there Zack was going
wild on the whoa whoa whoa oh it's me
who's that who's that idiot
Oh me welcome everybody today we got a
heck of a show planned thank you to quip
and honey for sponsoring our episode
unfortunately PewDiePie couldn't make it
as we scheduled him we are we are trying
to schedule him for next week so look
forward to that
[Music]
so Presidents Day came everybody had a
nice long weekend Ian as I understand it
spent the weekend with the wild card out
in wherever they are I'm not gonna say
where they are they might be here they
might be yeah well who knows Ian how was
your date I was great a lot of fun I got
back yesterday it was nice little little
vacay
have you guys consummated the
relationship no that is not christ-like
not cool
I'm offended you'd even say that
actually yeah that's that's pretty
messed up dude what yeah you guys you
know about Ian's faith is faith in Kanye
are you saying because you because
you're a fan of Kanye that you've gone
devout or is that just you're making a
joke you don't want to talk about your
sex life I'm just saying man what bass
God three always yeah I think he's I
think he's hit a homer
I'm sure well good for you she sounded
very happy when I spoke I spoke to her
I'm talking to Ian about work and I say
say hi to uh can I say her name here
wildcards fine well Curt I can't say her
name her name is wildcard okay that is
legally so I say say hi to a wild-card
because she helped Ian with something he
worked on as I tell her thank you and I
wish her well and he goes oh she can
hear you she's on speaker he had me on
speaker the whole time
Ian had me on speaker I was having an
elaborate conversation about work and he
I'm not speaker for the whole time with
wild card in the room with him I was
like bro you had me on speaker the whole
time what I mean what are you thinking
in not only is it rude to a normal
person but I'm a celebrity you can't
speak you phone me you are you decide to
nd8
you signed an nd8 she didn't sign it we
kind of classified stuff were you guys
it doesn't matter
everything I say is privileged well okay
so I wasn't planning on having a full
phone call with you I had called you
because I needed a code to access
certain account and so I had you on
speaker to type in the code and then you
continued the conversation which was
very lovely it's always nice to chat
klutz then I did not switched off this
video anything he did not expect it to
chitchat I wasn't chitchat we're talking
about work you were just going on and on
about how was your day how's the weather
nothing I'm like I gotta go wow you're
doing stick but what you actually did is
you didn't click the speaker button I
will pick up the phone when your boss
who you respect it's talking about
privileged information that you've
signed an NDA I did lift the phone and I
carried it into another room but then I
walked back and said oh here she is is
that what happened yes because when I
was on the speaker and I said Sam that's
do and I just outed her you can't I'll
go back to wild card I'll bleep you
impose doesn't matter all right I'm
pretty sure I've said her name already
on this you know but no I was I
I asked her I says Sam hammer it in
there really I said let's try what do
you think I said what do you think about
the fact that Ian has me on speaker and
she said I got to be honest I was a
little thrown off when he put you on
speaker I thought it was rude she told
me like she feels odd wow she really
said yeah she was no well I might
respect points went up for a big time I
was like I was like Ian you're out Sam
is it I could feel the lull of the
conversation and then I walked back into
the room as that happened at the same
time I would not breach your trust like
that come on come on well I do feel a
kinship to Sam and I do feel like she's
part of the circle of the trust but you
got who to come on
what if I told you about now Who am I
kidding there's also we can all attest
you are a big speakerphone guy
yeah but I'm the boss especially when
like shredders everything everything I
decide what the privilege there was the
hardest thing I have ever seen in life
you had we're talking to us if you had
speaker on in the car with the window
down shredder was barking in the back
and you were slurping but like you can
hear Dan laugh but in you can't really
hear when he's laughing I guess I had to
hand the phone to Dan cuz I could not
because I just lost it no respect
yeah I don't know I was just I asked
what is going on over there I didn't
know anything funny was happening at all
okay well yeah
and had a good weekend it's good to be
back gonna be better it's good to have
you back I appreciate that thank you
another funny thing to happen loaf drama
and the backstage is that we're I didn't
want to say what it was I don't even saw
anyone about Zacks comment how do i
frame this because I don't want to
insult that I don't want to insult you
know what I'm saying you look I know you
thing do I just say it like it is
I mean ya know you could say Dan or did
Zack was looking at something involving
certain people and made a certain call
obviously I see yeah I don't I don't
want to insult the people who don't
deserve it but we were reviewing
something involving females that Zack
was handling I mean it's probably
obvious and Zack just goes I'm just
gonna have to say what it is just let it
out yeah just let it out
I'm sorry I'm apologized to anyone I
don't share that opinion this is Zacks
opinion and that's why it's funny Kazak
was handling all the applications for
the bachelor season two with elos
brother and I say Zack how was it
looking how are the applicants and he
says it goes honestly they're just a
bunch of dogs and we were all shocked by
that or like a bunch of dogs I wasn't
here so it's so graphic do you refer to
women as dog oh look I was trying to be
humorous okay no you were I came out Rob
they weren't my type
how about that I just I didn't I didn't
find him attractive I'm sorry okay well
I did think it was funny was just
shocking
he knows funny I asked Sam yes Sam she I
said what do you think about Zack coy I
think what happened is that I asked you
what's happening with that and what do
we have so far and you said Zack says we
just have a bunch of dog well in the
words of the track I think Ian said they
don't
in the words of Zack they're just a
bunch of dog I don't mean to be degree
like it was fun but I was like wow Zack
and well you know but then but then I
was surprised
Ian's girlfriend said what do you think
about that I asked her she said well
frankly I'd have to see the pictures
[Laughter]
gotta stay I I have a certain type yeah
what is your humans apparently yeah
humans what's your type I mean my
current my girlfriend now she's my type
describe her long brown hair petite
petite you don't smile go on I think
that's everybody's type just like
there's a certain like personality trait
I don't know for you know Pitzer or
button how do you see personality
through a picture you can tell are you
are you are you tits or ass why would I
ask you you're an ass man yeah so do you
not consider I've always wanted us about
Aspen do you not consider boobs like
what is the ratio if you look at a girl
and you say her ass is like this good
but her boobs are I'm not liking her
boob so like are you willing to like
knock at their boobs at all if her ass
is like fat or like how does that work
out yeah yeah you could put it that way
it's all ass you don't care about the
boobs you know I mean of course you do
you want
you know something but you don't you
your requirements are not a lot on the
boobs no yeah no so if a girl has like a
2 out of 10 boobs
what's a 2 out of 10 boob well I don't
know everyone has their own preference
on boobs it's hard to because for
example for me size isn't a factor I
don't care about sides but I'm I'm more
of a tit man myself okay and it's not
about size it's more about the perky
Ness and the nipple and all that ela for
example has incredible boobs you
wouldn't expect but I always say she has
secret boobs as like
and those things are [ __ ] you
unexpected but like I'm just trying to
get the hard as that so graphic I'm
gonna back Zach up on this because I too
would consider myself and ask me and I
would say yeah I mean as long as nipples
your game ever see for me
so what's not game like someone with
like um flat flat back that does that
kill your vibe if there's a flat ass but
like perfect it's yeah kind of does see
did you see for me on if there's if I
don't like the tits then I'm not
interested and I hate shallow I am but
I've been with girls that I didn't like
who didn't like with the rack and that
was a no but to me I'm just it kills the
attraction and so obviously you know I
was younger I would say the boobs were a
bigger deal but you know I got I got a
theory you go from boobs to ass and then
you become a leg man
leg man as you get older I've remained
staunchly at it man my whole I'm
consistent I mean that's not to say I
don't like a fat ass but for me the tits
is what seals the deal okay and then
that the ass for me is like whatever the
tits has to be there now in you chime
another everybody's given their
preference what okay about I like legs
or as are you evil watching the show
there are no legs on the table tits are
actually I just really love a good
personality why do we even have him like
why do you have a mic dude let's put the
robot in I know we got to get robot Ian
he's way more interesting than real and
he's uh in the factory right now I'd say
that Ian do you refuse to answer do you
refuse to answer this question I know I
did I said I I like legs and ass okay so
we got three
I cement there and then just that just
to emphasize because I want to
understand this if tits are weak but the
ass is fat you're good
if the ass is weak you're out yeah I
mean I got to be honest I've I've been
in that exact scenario before Wow
it's so interesting but I've stopped
seeing a girl you're not attracted it
was it was it wasn't like the
deal-breaker but it certainly was a
factor you need a data would you guys
eat ass because one big enough guys are
so into ass it's all no but no Zack
would eat ass I'm sure of it probably
[Laughter]
sauce on there he'd eat that ass horsey
sauce you wouldn't eat ass what this
horsies no no no I get like a queen like
freshly showered right out of the shower
no really no iiv nice out of the shower
there's nothing wrong with there but I
feel like you guys are being so
repressed that you're like so repulsed
you into ass out of the shower but
you're an ass man yes I've eaten ass yes
once the last time you ate ass is
something do you like your ass being
eaten sighs no I don't go anywhere near
that I had a girlfriend college she
always tried to put a finger in my ass
no I was always out I was always like no
no no no but that but I'm not trying to
I'm not trying to shame anyone I think I
just wasn't ready for it I was fresh I
mean that would that was my first like
sexual experience like I lost my
virginity to this girl and she was a lot
more experienced than me not to brag but
you know and she but she would but I
wasn't ready for the finger in the ass
oh you're a little older you spread
those cheeks
[Music]
didn't ask permission no just like went
for it yeah I gotta tell you I can't
believe a minute admitting this but uh
exact same thing for me first girl has
ever with she did that and it really
pissed me off it was [ __ ] up they she
did she did she penetrate him or did she
just go for it like he just kind of went
for it and I pretty much immediately was
like what the [ __ ] you doing because it
takes I mean to actually penetrate you
would take some at force yeah as she so
she actually forced her way in deep did
her finger go to like the first knuckle
it was so she just started like
caressing my [ __ ] I think just she
was probing to see how comfortable I was
yeah I guess I mean this is a long time
ago it was this is in high school I mean
so I don't remember how many know yeah
that's a high school girl mine was in
college I didn't even know people did
that
in high school I had no knowledge of
that in butthole was a little bit older
more experienced so yeah I mean almost
the same situation you just described
I'm not saying I wouldn't enjoy these
days because I've been around the block
and you know you want something a little
more exciting I'm talking directly to
you yeah but at the time when you're
when you're having your first sexual
experience like that's a lot that's a
lot to take process yeah it's a lot to
process exactly were you scared no no I
know it I was just she I think actually
what I think happened is she touched the
ass and then she said do you like that
and I didn't know yeah that's why it
wasn't that wild okay the grand scheme
of things it's not that wild I suppose
he knows crazy when I the first time I
had sex the condom broke
that's the condom broke pretty crazy
yeah that's all I got
I've been there I think it's only her
stone though that would be really scary
I think it only happened to me twice in
my life for the condom broke but one was
the very first time
that's weird luck yeah she didn't want
to take my virginity this girl cuz I she
asked if I'd ever had sex and I said no
and then she so she was like oh she's
just been when I was like no no it's
fine I want to do it and the condom
broke and she's like oh we should do it
it's a sign I was like there's no such
thing as a sign Oh whew
she said she when she saw the condom
broke she's like oh it's a sign because
she didn't want to take my virginity I
was like there's no such thing as a sign
you know I was 19 everybody around me
had already lost their virginity but
when at what point did it break
like like immediately like I put it on
and I did like one thrust and then was
it broke damn no no no but it was just
one it was just it was in and out and
broke and then I just put on another one
interesting sorry yeah so you guys so
Dan your ask man that doesn't eat ass
you ever slip a finger in the ass damn
no no I'm not yeah I just I don't but I
don't believe you I don't believe you
okay
I don't believe you you're an ass man
you don't even touch that well you don't
eat that so you don't finger not oh I'm
not an [ __ ] man no it's like saying
I'm not a tip man but I'm not into
nipple
do you agree Zach no that nipple is way
more integral okay I I gotta agree with
Ethan on this one and Zach do you and
Ian do you agree wait what is the
question the question is if you're in as
a man he's talking about like feet he's
not even listening there's not even
listening I go Ian what do you think
what are we talking about are you even
listening in I'm watching your mouths
move it's not you're in the zone what's
the question if a nipple is okay if
you're an ass man
if you're an ass man and you are
apparently an ass man right do you think
that to say I says Dan you don't need to
ask you don't finger ass
how are you an ass man that's like
saying I'm a tip man but I don't care
about the nipple
I see so you think Dan is played with an
[ __ ] yes yeah I'd probably oh so Ian
just confirm he's [ __ ] with an [ __ ]
I'm just saying if you like an ass yeah
exactly
yeah you know what I'm saying if you if
you like do you like something you like
something there you go
dan has shut down I don't know I'm not
lying I mean Dan doesn't like what what
was that I last thing I accused of lying
he got really upset about what was it no
it's like a daily occurrence no no no
there was nothing of him looking at
instagrams right because I said he's
long well maybe you should be more
honest I won't QZ of lying I have no
reason to lie about this if you ate a
ass you'd be honest yeah absolutely
come on I was just open about her but
just now I said okay my first sexual
experience she's put a finger in my ass
okay I choose the baby died you're right
then I'll choose to believe what
happened if you came across a fake but
are you get interesting
Oh like a girl with those implants or
whatever yeah it seems it's a little
weird but I don't know you take you can
the ride the thing about that ass is
that it's the muscle so that I think the
attraction of the ass is that like is
that like you can do stuff with it like
I think when you have sex with a girl
with a fat ass she can do more with that
muscle and so when you have a fake
muscle it's kind of just dead weight
mm-hmm I guess I'll say is a tit man
implants for me are immediate turnoff
really yeah yeah I don't really like it
either
I mean mate maybe the really good ones
but you can't tell but I feel like I can
always tell facts
you like fake titties uh sure
I mean when I was like when I was
younger I guess I liked it but as I grew
and yeah I don't know I the thing is
fake titties look good in clothing do
you like
Oh check out my but once you're naked
they just throw just everywhere III
really get older like you appreciate
more natural you know mmm or natural
beauty okay I feel like we covered a lot
of ground here also have to report that
Dan is bitterly jealous of my diablo
three crits hold on he's grabbing some
mail
I've been keep on playing Diablo 3 I
just want to keep reporting on that I'm
on rift 99 and I am paragon level 750
and I'm happy to report that my highest
crit Dan listen closely was four three
trillion and I was just saying that
you're bitterly jealous of my high job
low Chris thank you Dan three trillion
what how high have you kratom diablo 3
oh i don't wanna brag yeah you haven't
but gotten this tube don't you stick he
didn't come thanks Dan
and then finally before I move on to our
headline stories I want to say that I
love talking about this because I
discovered that Bloomberg Michael
Bloomberg really triggers Dan and Ian
they hate Michael Bloomberg I know I
endorsed Bernie Sanders already for
president and donated $1,000 but um
Bloomberg is gonna be on the debate
stage tomorrow for the first time and
I'm gonna be watching very closely to
see how he performs but he's pulling
number two nationally he passed sleepy
Joe Biden that happened sloppy joe biden
he just came out of nowhere
waiting dude dude spent like three
hundred thirty million dollars and he's
gonna spend two billion is that epic
because before it wasn't in any pulse
was he like well it was in some no he
yeah he's it's been he's been steadily
climbing and I think I think all these
campaigns and even this this [ __ ] Jerry
one it's all working cuz everybody's
just Michael Bloomberg on the mind you
know and when I put on the news it's
always Michael Bloomberg this Michael
Bloomberg attacked Bernie and Bernie
attacked Bloomberg and I just saw today
in the latest poll he's pulling number
two that is shocking behind Bernie
nationally he's a head of sloppy joe
well that is not shocking well Joe Biden
in the beginning of this race was like
number one by far right until people
heard him talk yeah I did it what was
that new one that Vic burger did that it
of the wise lying
I don't think watch it on the show let
me put down why why why why why I love
Joe Biden he's like such a mean machine
and I love kids sitting on my lap and I
love kids he's really not I think he's
really not nervous he's shot again he's
like wow this is gold the reporter
[Music]
and it's like I don't hate too much on
this clip those people can be annoying
yeah but the way he reacted I mean hello
you're gonna be President you can hit
the [ __ ] every day but look how he like
trips of his eyes and then the lights
[Music]
just a good sound bite I want the Y
version of this so what do you guys
think are you about Michael Bloomberg
being on the stage tomorrow Danny and
aunt Co I'm glad that he's gonna be
there because I mean I think a large
part of why he's doing so well is he's
throwing half a billion dollars on ads
that just attacked Trump relentlessly
and everything and people outside of New
York City aren't really familiar with
him or who he is or the fact that he's a
little short manlet annoying nasally
dude he is five eight by the way yes as
we discussed last week not five Forrest
so but so he was the mayor of New York
right he was the mayor of New York for
three terms and that's a long time how
was he perceived as the mayor good uh
well cleaned up the city the city was a
dangerous place lots of crime I mean I
New York that's what New Yorkers say did
you live in New York during the time he
was mayor Danny I didn't know okay so
then they're based on people who lived
in New York at the time they said very
nice things about Michael Bloomberg dad
Zach rode bastard and when he starts
eating go ahead then I don't think all
of the black and brown kids who grew up
in New York City under his rule feel
that way about him let's just leave it
at that
actually I think he I think he has
really he pulls really well among black
voters I saw that which is weird I agree
because this whole stop and frisk thing
is definitely his biggest quote
controversy but I have a theory about
Michael Bloomberg that I'm gonna lay on
you right now Dan
so all these conservative Trump voters I
mean there's a lot of I'm not saying all
Trump voters are racists okay I'm not
saying that I would say the majority of
Trump voters are good kind sweet hearted
people they just want to see the best
for this country there are racist people
though or might maybe not even racist
people though but they look at the media
as like oh just another good guy or
maybe even just another white guy being
accused of being racist I think there's
a lot of people like that who will
almost I think this stop and frisk thing
could even help Michael Bloomberg what
would with people that are Trump
supporters yes there's a lot of people
who are disenchanted with Trump but they
don't see a better alternative there's a
lot of people that are disenchanted with
Trump because you know he has a 95
percent approval rating with Republicans
I think there's a lot of people there
who don't see a better option in the
Democrats because they see Bernie
Sanders as too radical because he's way
too easy to vilify and although I love
Bernie and I'm not agreeing with them
and I don't think he's a boogeyman I
think socialism capitalistic socialism
has I don't know why they always point
to Venezuelans [ __ ] like that Nazi
Germany it's like hello all of
Scandinavia is is having this and
they're like the happiest countries on
earth they have like the most like
flourishing societies mmm-hmm it's like
we just ignore the fact that Scandinavia
exists but anyway I agree with Bernie's
dream but he's so easy to vilify and
this whole brainwashing campaign to make
him label ISM some some crazy socialist
autocrat
I've already seen it they go look at
videos wheeler the price of bread went
up to $1,000,000
that's what Bernie Sanders wants for you
like what it's so stupid but anyway a
lot of these people who are maybe soured
on Trump or are independent or on the
fringe of the Republican Party well look
at a guy like Michael Bloomberg who used
to be used to be a Republican and he
they seem as like an outsider because
they're like oh well he's a just being
accused of racism like Trump they're
gonna be like that's my kind of guy also
a lot of people wanted a successful
businessman when they chose Trump but
Bloomberg is the actual successful
businessman Bloomberg is most definitely
but I don't know anything about him so
I'm not saying one way or another I do
want to watch the debate all I know
about Bloomberg is that he was a
long-term mayor of New York City very
rich guy he has some controversies about
stop and frisk and I'm looking for I'm
sure they're gonna ask him a lot of
questions about on the debate stage so
we'll see but I do think that there's um
I think there's a lot of people from the
Trump camp who will like Michael boom
blame berg who would never vote for
Bernie thoughts Dan I think it's
delusional brilliant Trumpy
people love the Trump supporters love
Trump look they're not gonna switch over
are you kidding me he's gonna get
annihilated by Trump if he becomes the
nominee you think Bernie will do
landslide really landslide win for Trump
cuz I think you like nominee why yeah
I'm not sure I agree with you there
because they're the same but Bloomberg
is have you seen any like interviews
with him or no that's why I'm really
looking forward to tomorrow night okay
well the conversation about it after the
debate because you're gonna see who
Michael Bloomberg is and he's like a
really kind of wiry Dee's Jewish right I
believe he used to is yeah because he
has this whole like New York Jew thing
where they did he is um not a very
charismatic he was nice he was the mayor
for 11 years I mean that's that's a
pretty long
stint as as a public service and and
this is a very rich man this he was
already super rich and he dedicated 11
years of his life to public service I
mean that's pretty admirable do you
disagree
I do but we're also waiting minutes we
should go to bring that okay we should
go to break but what's not admirable
about dedicating 11 years of your life
to public service I went is admirable
admirable for Trump to do that I guess I
mean ultimately it's just like that's
such a that's what a loaded question you
the thing is the thing is that the
presidency has this prestige in power
I mean mayor of New York obviously is a
prestigious slimly prestige ISM it's
more it's one of the most powerful
political offices in this country it's
more powerful than probably the vast
majority of governorships of states I
agree it is it is definitely a powerful
seat but it's far cry from the
presidency
I'm sure well he's trying to buy his way
into that one too so and there you go
well let's go to break when we come back
we're gonna have the oh yeah the taste
test wow I can't wait for that really
filmed it to be honest with you guys
we filmed it at the beginning because we
want the burgers to rot so I'm gonna
show you now the fast food taste test
after this short commercial break
you know that honey is the free online
shopping tool that automatically finds
the best promo codes and applies them at
your cart and you know how great it
feels to save but do you know how great
it feels to save with honey saving with
honey feels like when you go and take a
dump and you go to wipe it up and
there's nothing on the first wife and
you don't even bother to go for a second
weight because you're like I know that
I'm clean down there that's what it
feels like to save with honey when Papa
John was in the house we entered a
couple of pies from Papa John calm look
at this coupon from honey
you saved $11.64 up a $54 purchase come
on that's like 20% I don't know the math
15% I don't know but this is money that
honey saved me automatically a checkout
I was going to buy some pies right when
I'm getting a checkout honey goes hold
on one sec boom automatically pies
almost $12 to savings it's happened to
me so many times
honey has found it's over 18 million
members over 2 billion dollars and
savings that's almost as much money as
Michael Bloomberg spent on on ads just
in the past three months
did you know honey supports over 30,000
stores online including Macy's targets
Sephora Best Buy and more and they're
adding more every day did you know that
users love honey that's why it has over
a hundred thousand five star reviews on
the google chrome store using honey
feels great it's a daily victory every
time you're on the internet everybody
loves it it's for me to install it takes
just a few clicks go to join honey for
free get honey for free at join
honeycomb / HP that's join honey calm /
h3
quip is the Alpha and Omega of
toothbrushing technology if you want
your mouth clean if you want your gums
clean if you want your Pratt's fresh you
will go to quip you will keep your mouth
clean and it is simple as good habits it
they they tell me to say this they say
it is simply this if you have good
habits you are good I thought my intro
was better but hey it's their copy
they're the ones pain that means if you
brush for two minutes twice a day and
floss regularly no matter what bread you
use your mouth will be good but here's
the thing quit makes that simple for you
starting with an electric toothbrush
refillable floss and anti cavity
toothpaste quips electric breath has
sensitive sonic vibrations with a
built-in timer and 30-second pulses to
guide a full and even clean the quip
floss dispenser comes with pre-marked
string to help you use just enough plus
quip delivers fresh breasts head brush
heads floss and toothpaste refills right
to your door every three months with
free shipping so your routine is always
right join over 3 million healthy mouths
and get equipped today starting at just
$25 and if you go to get clip comm / h3
right now you'll get your first refill
for free
that's your first refill free at get
clip comm / h3 spelled GE t qu IP comm /
h3 quip it's the good habits company
quit May Day
welcome back everybody to the
much-anticipated food challenge and
who's anticipated it more than me though
nobody you know we have a lot of people
often are requesting food taste tests in
the comments so I don't see those people
I dan Ian back me up people love this
people had I don't have an explanation
but if you love it thank you
but actually I'm really excited for
today's you know you hear about the
beyond me the impossible burger well we
have gone to all of the major fast-food
restaurants that offer a beyond meat
option and we are doing a blind taste
test before me I have starting I have a
Carl's jr. what do they call their
burger the mall star superstar or star
whatever it is crap burger I've got a
real beef and I got a fake beef and I'm
gonna taste both I'm gonna tell you
which I think is the meat and I'm gonna
tell you which one tastes better now I'm
gonna tell you for sure if I'm wrong
I'll [ __ ] eat my hat but see one Dan
is the is the fake meat or I'm the
[ __ ] Pope interesting and c2 is real
me if I'm wrong then I'll just give it
I'll just invest all my money or fake me
it right now but but but I could be
wrong I mean it would be awfully funny
if I was wrong hmm so I'm gonna go ahead
and take a bite of what I think is the
real meat first which is c2 um I mean
that's real meat
I mean here I'll show you guys what I'm
seeing I mean this is fake meat that's
real me come on
obviously right man does this meat all
right here we go I'm just eating a
burger now it's off we only do one byte
per
who said that rule people love to watch
me much
although gotta say too Carl's
surprisingly extremely expensive really
fast food yeah tell me the breath Zack
was the one who picked it up how much
did you end up spending there it's $41
what
well that was but we bought what four of
each compared three like three meat for
veggie yeah that's seven seven
sandwiches for $40 compared to Burger
King that was $23 an offensive Carl's
jr. that's what a sandwich should cost
the faculty Burger King selling over
half the price is disturbing this is
America no I do that so go back and
check our old to your list on fast food
yeah yeah city and we did rate Burger
King what D tier with a draft here it
was like it was okay I'm now taking a
bite so just to sorry to pause you but
is Zach Annie and also yes everything at
the same yes they should be doing me so
did you guys all take a bite of c2 there
munching right now do they know damn
what's what
yeah we didn't know we didn't uh
randomized it back here so I'm the only
clown that doesn't know the only clown
but you knew I mean come on I am now
taking a bite can you really not sure
into the mic I cannot no I can't
yeah I know it's a joke but it's also
good yeah well that's definitely to bed
you the second one mm-hmm okay well you
did correctly identify them that being
said the taste is on point I mean for
that veggie yeah dude I actually might
say that um it tastes better it's weird
because like these fast-food burgers
they're they don't use that much meat
cuz it's expensive cameo napkin and so I
and I know this is really weird to say
but I think this has more of a
flavor than the actual meat because
they're just they're just it's a really
small patty and you just can't get that
much out of it good smoky flavor right
thank you make you suck suck and so so I
bet it's really good a lot of people are
probably wondering is Ethan not
vegetarian right I'm mostly vegetarian
maybe it like once a week I'm very proud
of the meat games I've I'm very proud of
myself I've cut back on meat a lot since
my darby's meat mountain like how often
like once a week once a week okay yeah
no I'm I don't know I don't eat meat at
home I only me eat meat when we go to
you well I I genuinely think let me let
me take another tape no you're done Nate
- let me just I want to be sure there's
more to come
I like I'm on this earth we can't call
this a taste I mean that's just passed
me all them you know I'm into hate them
you can taste your burger you look I was
thinking maybe I'll wait for all the
vegetarian ones and then I tried them
all and tell you which one's the best
that's exciting let's do that good or
did you guys yeah I can taste family
onion incredible approach I like you
know I like I do I like it I like it
can't tell on your own well it's a
pretty good approach it might be a
little slow after we've already tasted
every one of them I think I'm with you
with the impossible burger having a
little more kick to it than any other
one really inside and thank you I'm
doing a or two are they the same price
yeah are you impossible burger on the
wrap no this is from these Zac did you
have a preference about burgers the same
thing there I I like the meat one you do
like the me yeah okay I'm gonna tell you
right off the bat on fat burger I'm not
having such an obvious no meat
conclusion
let's say look way more similar so
that's f1 you got a good look at that
ela and then that's f2 they look way
more similar
that being said f1
I'm gonna call is the veggie saying f1
is the veggie okay all right
f1 is the veggie this is fat burger this
is fat burger which I guess is not a
national thing so maybe we should
extract like I don't maybe not everybody
knows what fat burger is it's a little
bit of like a higher wall it's not quite
like a that's right because to your
point it will be too slow hmm you know
there's been sitting out for a minute
and then I don't think the meat stands
up to time as well as the veggie one but
I'm not a fan of fat burger so much I
don't like they put mustard on it I
don't like the bread is marks no I'm
there sweet relish on I mean that [ __ ]
out of here I don't like it so all so
far and away the most expensive it was
for seven burgers I think $67 oh my god
what quite an investment we made on the
segment now I'll say right off the bat
Carl's jr. vastly superior burger whoa
I'm just being realized but that that
was f1 here or that was f2 so this is f1
this is what I thought was the the
veggie burger but it looks so much like
me my god if I didn't have the
comparison I would guess I couldn't even
tell this wasn't me that's f2 right
there f1 this is definitely not me and I
don't know why they seem to be using
fake cheese as well for that it's not
melted out of these it's kind of watery
watery so
I don't like it there's f12 bed.you f1
is the veggie okay there's no there's no
getting meat past you yeah um you know
zach is right it is kind of watering hmm
that's weird
did you try the Carl's one I try to I
tried both the costumers way better way
better right no one is really good
mm-hmm so I will say first of all fat
burger and not a fan I'm into second of
all pepper took the longest to make two
right Ian yeah it took him a while to
get they were boiling it in water and
they use vegan cheese so here I will say
about fat burger aesthetically that's
insane how it looks like me
yeah you might get a close-up of that
again like if you don't see that next to
anything that just looks like ground
beef that being said it does taste like
me but I guess I don't like fat burger
so I get I don't like neither of these
to be honest with you I don't like it I
don't like it so you know still couldn't
fool me although they aesthetically is
very very very good
so one the bun sucks like the Carl's jr.
buns like really saw nice and that bun
was stale quite frankly so that's for
you
this is uh Boyka king boycott you know
it's funny I saw the veggie one and I
was like oh that's so obvious and I saw
the real one and it looks so shady that
is what's obvious right seeing the real
one so be one okay so here we go
these took forever to make it long so
like Carl's jr. I think that I'm gonna
spot these immediately this is this is
the fake one I'm saying B to say B to is
fake yeah okay and then b1 is is a real
burger but I got to tell you like that
meat don't look that good either
at least on camera they look identical
they do
I mean b2 is the fake one
well don't tell me yet but I know
right so anyway let's try the what I
think to be the fake one first be - here
we go everybody listen closely as I
munch this another mic a lot of
expectation for this one cuz again we
did rate Burger King ft r chiming in are
you not trying it oh you trying to iron
oh exactly what you're not saying
anything
I'm just he said that fat burger tastes
like water
what did you think about Carl's jr. oh
it was the best of arm and did you have
a preference between real and fake or
like the real one right you had said
that now I remember you are here okay so
now I'm we rated Burger King II so we
did it E
oh yeah they said B no no he so I'm
going in for what I perceived to be the
real one on Burger King so here we go
both are very flavorless yeah King is
trash it tastes like trash you know they
say in the Burger King lab they're like
cuz first I tried that one B - was I
right by the way B - is the favor B - is
the fake yes so when I tried that I was
like wow this is really flavorless and
not good and I tasted this one I was
like oh they're emulating the meat in
the Burger King lab they're like weak
they're like you know what we can't make
this too flavorful because our normal
meat doesn't taste good so by far Carl's
jr. was the best there's more there's we
have one more but that was the end of
the burgers okay our last option here is
some tacos from Del Taco because they
are for their taco meat they have beyond
me so let me bring those out - well I'll
say Burger King I think they both rate
the same yeah I can handle that
so in summary Carl's jr. but first of
all the burger and then pass
Birger are far and away the best burger
on this table the impossible burger I
would say tastes as good or even better
than the real burger it had a good
amount of everything to like the Burger
King is too dry and empty and then fat
burger is too packed with dads no shell
taco just reeled in horror feeling about
this right now
I will say as you're serving like the
tacos did not keep as well as the
burgers bringing here I'll be the judge
of that
so that's a Beyond taco there's suppose
the reason I know this is there supposed
to be hard tacos and I feel like songs
right now so that's not a great sign I
will say that fat burger aesthetically
nailed nailed it that's what I'm
surprised you [ __ ] on that one advice
good but it looks it looks good yeah I'm
giving it the highest grade possible for
looks alright here's d1 d2 good luck oh
maybe I shouldn't look at it do I meant
to show yep so this one could be
actually more difficult which is yeah
cuz you know so far I'm adding it so I
just look like a paste
I'm gonna guess right off the bat that
that's the fake you see it I mean you
don't see much you know and then this
one you're right you don't see much I
got I think I just gotta taste it I
don't want to open it and inspect it cuz
I feel like that would be too easy yeah
but maybe I will
this has the same d2 is fake I didn't
sell but let me taste like chilli it's
awful I don't have her eat at Del Taco
to people like del Taco uh Dan well I
stopped by there this morning to get
these and they had like a breakfast wrap
thing and I was hungry so I went for it
I gotta say that was actually pretty
good
I was surprised um but I can't vouch for
the tacos so d2 what I'm calling the
fake meat tastes like [ __ ] d1 real meat
I am assuming let's go
I just don't like how they season the
meat tastes like chili so it tastes the
same well I think d1 is real meat if I'm
wrong them you are not wrong you were
four four four my dude you uh you know
your meat you know your way around some
meat well give it up for me I it almost
tastes like you're just eating beans
right mm-hmm it's not bad though for a
vegetarian option you're right it's not
bad for a vegetarian option mm-hmm Ian
and Zach thought we didn't try it
Oh here grab a taco make yourself sick I
might be pushing it don't eat they'll
talk oh that poor Zach was so sick don't
eat they'll talk oh my dear yeah I'm not
gonna eat it that's that's a risk we're
not willing to take with you
Ian did you have I got a say in the
meantime yeah I've been going back to
this Carl's jr. but that's Wow
did you go back for the meat or the
veggie one yeah uh the veggie one mm-hmm
if you go like flavor now to eat burgers
in the future mm-hmm would you order the
beyond one if I went to Carl's jr. yeah
yes Wow and out of the four places you
like Carlos Abeche so really the veggie
one is the to do Carl's jr. is by far
the best thing on this table Wow yeah
that makes me very happy to hear that
yeah and is taking the crown hang on
what's crazy I'm just gonna be totally
honest with you guys here okay
that's not an honest reveal this is good
for thumb in crash that turns me on Papa
save us Papa please that bite was too
big I couldn't really taste it great
they just shoved it back it was a
mistake how many burgers are you eating
here in total you know just took a
little nibble of that BK dude I like the
bed you want better for sure
Wow for sure for sure now it's part you
know I want the veggie one to win but it
is possible that it is because it was
sitting there for 45 minutes before you
ate it
maybe the neon is better fresh but I
don't think so Carl's jr. veggie burger
and I agree I mean this is bomb this is
a really good burger so well taco is
awful oh I hated the dope so did you
guys have any trouble distinguishing
Harbor you was it easy for you guys as
it was for me well then they knew I
didn't all right
I didn't randomize it for them the
whopper I mean they just look like [ __ ]
they both suck like watery yeah sure but
I am so impressed by the Karlsen know
that the aesthetic look of the wrapper
get one more look at that i mean it is
remarkable is that uh one or two is that
the F one is the fake one water but I
mean dude the meat looks ridiculous
yeah that look at that how it's like
hanging off it's the real deal
you got a taste of [ __ ]
but you said it was watery mine wasn't
watery I don't know what that means how
mine was I don't know exact and mutable
said watery just mustard and sweet
relish like I had what's a easier way to
what about sweet rep maybe it's sweet
relish that's ruining it for me I'll
tell you right now which ones ruin it
for me
am i bitter sweet relish I think I
remember you knocking mustard before
though you're kind of a mustard hater no
he's not mustard I like mustard on hot
dogs by itself just muster
I like mustard in egg salad a little bit
other than that the [ __ ] out of my plate
Wow what about in tuna you like are you
trying to give me a plague I like tuna
salad like you know celery mayo mustard
guys I don't know the way you said it
was just like all right let me try this
fat burger one more tuna there's not
good okay the segment over alright just
eating now so in short oh all right
sweet you can't put sweet relish on a
burger let's [ __ ] horrific now you
want to know some disappointing news
when I was researching this yesterday is
that McDonald's has already rolled out
these veggie burgers in Europe but has
said they have no plans to do so in the
United States what yeah
why why is that it's super weird right
everybody's doing it and but McDonald's
needs to be they're even doing it there
just remember refusing to do it in
America for some reason dedicated to not
giving an option to vegetarians
I guess they probably did the research
and it's not it's just not worth it to
them
yeah like fans I agree I mean I would
probably order that occasionally going
through McDonald's I of course check
because as you'll recall from our tier
list you you
rated McDonald's very highly in the
fast-food tier list yes so I wanted to
see if they had something to participate
but uh no veggie options they over there
you know what I feel like right now I
feel like I'm gonna get sick for sure
and I'll tell you why
I feel like I just created like like
Burger czars
cuz there's so many here Mel Dean burger
Roma berger rona berger rama no they're
all these little burger dnas melting in
a wild habitat
they've all been rotting here like you
know how they say that SARS and corona
get started when you introduce wild
animals to kureta baited animals and
humans and the virus jumps yeah so now
I've introduced this environment with
all these different meats and fake meats
and you got viruses jumping back and
forth mutating and I think I just I
think I'm gonna die you know what it
might be - we remember a few weeks ago
we unsealed the bill Delphine jar we
also have Skippy's link right in if I
was like a witch notions those are like
most rare killer ingredients can make a
hell of a potent potion in here oh all
right so yeah I just looked it up to
confirm in Europe we got a they call it
the mick vegan and it's a safe free
burger market that yeah McVie ghen
wouldn't go over well here yeah
it needs to be like the Incan haters
right vegan it's almost like a naughty
word so it need to be like the Mick Mick
beyond Mick possible they do the
impossible to make possible that's not a
bad title to make fake that's an awful
title no doc why Mick no it's Mick no
well it's called a MC McDonald's some
people say Macs and paper some people
say men and Mick here I think is the Big
Mac not big Mick Big Mac I think hear
people say McDonald's I think it's a
regional thing yeah
like a like Irish name you say MC like
mcdougal mcdougal some people are
mcdougal ah
so people are mcdougal it's news to me
you can say yeah I feel like I say Mac
it might be a regional thing you know I
remember while I was watching Pulp
Fiction and I heard Jules say McDonald's
and I thought he was doing shtick
oh but yeah people call it in Europe I
guess cuz in Israel you would say mmm
McDonald's you just like McDonald's MEC
say it again McDonald's CSUN's like you
said McDonald's really mm-hmm
say MEK but say McDonald's again three
times McDonald's go ahead Michael
Brown's McDonald's McDonald McDonald's I
don't hear Mick well how about we called
the de Mick the Mick the Mi'kmaq Mac
Micmac patty-whack I listen the segment
good so what we're gonna do is cut it
well we actually we filmed this segment
first thing we got in here because we
don't want these burgers to rot
what time you got is by these cuz they
may have already rotted I got mine at
like 9:45 and then 45 it is 12:30 right
now buddy ran a little bit late but
that's some three hours yeah well I
remember from my food service days uh
you could stay on refrigerator for four
hours before it uh so I think we're I
think we're okay
oh and you know these burgers have extra
shelf life yeah all the probably full of
a ton of preservatives well last time we
did a food taste us I had like major
diarrhea was that the [ __ ] Arby's was
guitar yeah the roast beef the roast
beef yeah yeah that'll do it
well let's hope I mean I kind of already
feel it coming on but I'll be sure to
update you
it's the first thing you've eaten today
not breakfast okay okay that's good all
right let's end this and go back to the
show thank you all for enjoying this
very special h3 podcast presents welcome
back I hope you enjoyed the taste test I
will say they say you shouldn't mix your
alcohols I feel like you shouldn't mix
your meats either I just went to the
bathroom to pee during the break and I
was like you know sometimes when you go
to pee and you're like oh I actually
need a [ __ ] but I'm not doing that here
not now
but I had that feeling and I'm still
fighting it back thank you for your
commitment thank you to the show thank
you for acknowledging my commitment well
let's get on with it shall we
Sonic the Hedgehog has been a hotly
debated topic on this podcast and I'm
actually shocked to see that it has
opened at number one grossing 58 million
dollars on the what timezone is that
just this is opening weekend yes correct
absolutely smash the box office and then
I mean Ian and Dan both saw it is that
right I thought Ian has a little bit of
Dan you're eating into the mic again
there's no reason for you to be eating
it to the mic and the burger is over I
didn't expect you to throw it to me I'm
sorry thanks Dan wait Joan are you
aiding the Carl's okay you sauce on it
without taking a bite of your burger
tell me what you thought yes it's a good
kids movie
I mean it wasn't didn't blow me away hey
it's moving yeah I actually didn't end
up seeing it mm-hmm
did you buy tickets a knock oh yes
that's correct
hmm so you paid you contributed to this
yeah I did interesting doing well well
how much did they spend I heard they
spent 90 million so I don't know I mean
even with this huge opening I feel like
I feel like we're gonna have to follow
this closer as long as they have a good
second weekend they'll be fine they'll
break even at least
well we'll keep an eye on that but what
I really want to talk about here today
is something we haven't talked about in
a moment I'm happy to announce that your
favorite brothers are back
Jake Paul and Logan Paul are both back
in the news
Jake Paul first of all launched this
absolute scam
Jake Paul is just at this point such a
douche it's a legit scam at this point
more before it was just like shady
content right like I mean first of all I
made a video about him and rice go I'm
doing this the gambling thing where you
you pay and open the mystery box that
was giving away the hundred fifty
million dollar bel-air mansion yeah
wonder who won that I think it was Jeff
Bezos what a coincidence
yeah wonder who we've got it icicles
somebody sent us that no I feel like at
this [ __ ] I made a huge mistake
mixer mates never makes me another
reason to go with the
[Music]
I feel like I got it are you right I'm I
wish I wasn't really Wow
god dammit I don't want to just go well
sometimes it passes I just I think I got
to just take care of this all right I
take back my applaud to you oh he's got
in the wet wipes - this is serious huh
we have a whole story
slash into wipes you know that you're
gonna clog the city all right well he's
got the wet wipes ready to go he's not
[ __ ] around all right uh I mean I
guess we'll just follow me back we'll be
right back
welcome back again I just I don't [ __ ]
like that anywhere else only here after
those food segments like you cannot
believe what just came out of me
I don't even want to talk okay [ __ ]
disgusting dude here of all places
did you get two paddles
no no again what can I tell you not only
was I in a hurry but they were out of
pads other way they were out of pads and
then it was a fresh roll because I
wanted to get some toilet paper throwing
the ball students splashed on me
it was out of roll so I was just clawing
at it manically tripping chunks of
toilet paper off just awful did you just
look inside the bowl afterwards and
you're just like what is wrong with me
looks like a mound of dirt like you know
outside of an ant hole a vaguely like or
like outside of a gopher hole just
mounds of dirt that's what it looked
like anything like thank you you said
you don't want to talk about it you
brought it up
you asked you just sent me off you asked
a question those your oh all right let's
just forget that ever happened these
food reviews are killing me right Jake
Paul we were talking about has launched
a what appears to be a total scheme
where is this where's the video of him
talking about it what a mess
here it is let's enjoy they say were
entitled and lazy they tell us to go to
college get a job retire at 65 how's
that working out for us
are your parents happy little bit this
is like a dollar store Tai Lopez it yeah
internet marketing totally I mean look
at like the bars and the texts and and
and notice all the royalty-free footage
is
Oh bat it's so poorly edited like he'll
talk about someone poor and it's just
like some royalty free like a baby who's
like it's just so bad I'm not I'm not
gonna say anything just just enjoy I'm
gonna start over let's take this in
together and then talk about it
say we're entitled in lays they tell us
to go to college get a job retire at 65
how's that working out for us
are your parents happy are they living
the life they wanted there's over one
trillion dollars in student loan debt
and people with outdated education who
can't even get a job for the student
loans they took out that now haunt them
for life maybe we're too young to have
experiences yet but if you're not then
you know exactly what I'm talking about
and now that enough of it our generation
is better than this we deserve better
we're smarter so what's the solution we
need to create a movement for our
generation one that inspires people to
take action to achieve livesey now the
dreams our parents have for us or our
society we need a movement that inspires
they don't live life on that that's
something else a movement that anyone
who's great just enough to follow can
have a much higher chance of becoming
financially free from the societal
cookie cutter nine-to-five jobs we were
all told to have the future is in our
hands are you with me no definitely not
it's so unbelievable to me you know so
this is a program that cost $20 a month
now first of all bro the fact that he
actually did seize it is projecting
success in the way he looks it's so
crazy he looks like such a douche I
think he's he's trying to be appealing
as like the successful young guy that
you should listen to because he knows
wasn't what's up he looks like such a
douche and by the way the last the last
business I recall Jake Paul running was
team 10 which imploded on itself was a
total disaster so what exactly do you
know about financial independence and
running a business also $20 a month
that's a lot that's more than Netflix
yeah $20 what is he gonna provide for
that so for $20 a month he sold you the
lifestyle
he's basically saying where did he say
to drop out of school he said in this
interview here look at this and he did
it right up they says where did he say
to drop out of school here the only
program which costs 20 dollars a month
will feature curated content from social
media influencers and business
entrepreneurs including Paul himself
ostensibly it's a how-to guide on how to
monetize an online presence although
Paul told variety it's for anybody who
wants insight on how to make money from
his/her their passion subscriptions also
include weekly group video calls with
Paul and guess experts I guarantee he's
not there in the VIP area were Paul oh
so here's a video of him announcing the
launch of his of his app it's just as
classy as you would imagine or not even
if half of the populace
I hear you guys go this is this is the
role model that they all want it was at
a mini-golf place too classy many people
there the video you just showed us
barely has any views yeah I think
they're just good I think they're just
using that as an ad they haven't really
launched a
[Applause]
those up on a balcony shouting inaudibly
down at people below him I love her guys
this is something I'm like really
passionate about did you say I don't
really agree with education and stuff
here it has a twit our education system
is worthless I'm fed up if I die I want
to die having made a real difference on
the word well he sounds fairly
uneducated so I'll agree that this is a
high school dropout yeah I went to
college I mean what does he know about
the education system he sounds like it
though he sounds like a buffoon so the
education system has failed him he's
right there's throwing money off the
balcony
[Music]
so here's this is what it means to not
go to college both but throwing money
off balcony and The Hunger Games what
kind of what bills are those coupons
really okay
are you sure no because it doesn't look
like real money awaits for me Gotha Jay
[Applause]
we can't afford you good bro so dawn I
sent you that's wait you should open
that up
he made that before this event Wow you
can't you're so elevated no go backward
I think we're missing oh my god it's
hard to get that past the fact that he
can barely talk but here we go here's
your leader for $20 a month
but no flutes and public speaking
classes and is any class the US
government is campaigning against I
can't say you know what he reminds me of
right now the that the kid who goes can
I you know when you know when you know
when kid and let's see if that worked
are you finding that clip oh yeah I feel
like that used to work but it's so old
now there's this one little kid who has
like a sweater he goes you know when you
can't when you win when when he can like
here's a tweet in the meantime it's time
to like I'm fed up with like the
government and [ __ ] and school and stuff
you know when like that's all this is a
movement for like I guess like school
$20 government by the way a mom he goes
our education system is worthless by the
way no punctuation he has an apostrophe
here but he hasn't punctuated the first
part or the eye
our situation is worthless I'm fed up if
I die I want to die having made a real
difference on the world was that gonna
do with education room so here he
tweeted this photo he said if you're
spelled you are it's not even a tweet
it's an image you can use punctuation
bro if you're confused at what the event
is tomorrow basically I'm sick of our
education system how was teaching kids
zero real life skills for them to secure
their own future
I'm creating a movement for everyone who
wants to take life into their own hands
and learn real life skills from actual
professionals why are kids sitting in
quote film class learning from a teacher
was never even made of film
I don't think anybody's doing that
neither is Jake Paul what are you
talking about it every scene his daily
vlogs dude I quit films I guarantee you
any film class and college is being
taught by somebody who makes films I and
that's just one example
but it's not true that's just the one
example I made off the top of my head
bro I was the kid in class who was the
smartest but wouldn't apply myself yeah
back it up Ella I was the kid in the
class who was the smartest but wouldn't
apply myself because I thought it was so
stupid to be sitting there but it'll but
it's all we are taught just sitting
there I'm just not letting it go anymore
without doing something about it
Wow let me read the comments on this top
level kids stay in school trust me
otherwise you'll sound like him it's
almost worse than tile open of course
it's worth at least time Tai Lopez has
some credential Tai Lopez is not
actually approaching kids no it's for
anybody but see Jake's whole thing is
like yeah he's going to kids and saying
[ __ ] school drop out of school and pay
me 20 dollars a lot but the dude can't
even punctuate a sentence I mean it's
like a run-on say it's written like and
what real-world skills does Jake what do
you mean there's been a finer an
imaginary 16 years old are you saying
that team ten is in here is a check mark
account replying whoever Kendra
Sunderland is I wish High School taught
me about credit job applications basic
car maintenance and buying a house
instead of the Pythagorean theorem which
I never [ __ ] use is that what Jake
Paul is doing about credit applied to a
job the dudes never had a job
Ethan don't go in it that's another
little Barnum star yeah well that's oh
good he's got the I wish I wish over to
learn to go in porn unlike everything
else I learned school
Wow where'd that me a huge thank you
like lick that [ __ ] and they're like are
you sure about this is Jake Paul and
Weston royal of course just such a
horndog Justin seriously what is Jake
Paul gonna upload he's gonna teach you
about paying a mortgage he's gonna
upload a vlog and in on April 15 saying
hey I just filed my taxes like what what
does he know I'm confused about what
does he know he doesn't do anything yeah
well what happens in the case of someone
like Jake Paul is that he has like
business partners who are just trying to
use him and he thinks it's cool because
he didn't give a [ __ ] he's what's the
fleeces fans so they are like we have
business experts and we're gonna teach
classes up he's not really involved he's
just selling it and his business
partners are gonna do everything but
it's still gonna suck Jake Paul's not
involved at all because obviously he has
no capacity is no capability to actually
run and manage a business so he's got
his business partner who's just trying
to fleece his fans as much as Jake Paul
is yeah and they're gonna they're gonna
try to make something but it's gonna be
garbage because nobody there actually
cares about it and it's gonna be
impossible to cancel your membership
that's that that's how they all work I'd
be surprised if anyone if many people
enroll in this though because this is an
awful patch man this is not a good [ __ ]
he he thinks is like embracing the fact
that he's so young and successful with
like no you know book shoe Asian kind of
I don't think he thinks about that much
I feel like he does I don't know Wow
because it's intentional like the AI is
not capitalized but then do you
understand if you are actually in
business and you send emails like that
every people will not take you seriously
if you become a serious person in a
serious business man and you're firing
off communications like he wrote and
that people will not take you seriously
like eventually you have to face the
real [ __ ] world and use punctuation
because you're not just some big like
people
dude you are gonna look like an idiot to
everybody that actually knows how to be
professional it's insane I don't think
he thought that much I think you may
lose just a buffoon
I think you're giving him way too much
maybe when asked if he thinks parents
would regard FF M s sending a dangerous
message to younger fans call paused
that's a tough question he said I would
say why would you ever stop your kid
from learning anything that is going to
make he or she's smart that sounds
terrible
and it doesn't have to be like I'm
taking this course and I'm dropping out
you literally told people to drop out of
school by the way this interviewer was a
hack because they just they didn't even
push beyond that they go do you think
it's dangerous telling kids to drop out
of school and pay you twenty else a
month that's a tough question I would
say why would you ever stop your kids
from learning anything and the
interviewers like dope makes sense
there's another clip of this party just
money raining down and people in a
Hunger Games situation grabbing $1 bills
secure an independent is to just throw
money away off balconies these people
are obviously paid like who brought a
sign yeah what does the sign say this is
such no no it says ideas are [ __ ]
without execution sorry Dan tell me
exactly what Dan shows up with this this
this is all there's not a single person
here who's a family ideas are [ __ ]
without execution why would any way show
up with a sign that said is that is that
maybe a Jake Paul catchphrase I mean
we're not as up-to-date on the on the
wall again today it I never heard anyone
else say it yeah but I mean what my way
these are like older people and then
this guy has a sign that says F F M
something
well yeah I deserve [ __ ] without
execution yeah what is this whole
situation was the J don't come at ya J
P's been banished yeah they're like we
don't need kids to see what happens when
you actually grow up when you turn from
us to to dull that ruins the illusion
[Applause]
there's a nightmare so that's what Jake
Paul has been up to I couldn't believe
it I gotta tell you I I started to feel
at some point that you know Jake is
maybe a little bit of a dumb-dumb but is
trying to make content and he's young
but this is like you're just trying to
scam kids well and to your point after
the last scam that I made a video about
with the loot crate boxes even then I
was like okay fine maybe he's actually
stupid and didn't think about it enough
and just took the sponsor well my point
is that after that yeah and he was like
you know what I know better now I
learned my lesson well he went and after
that did this so he really I think it
proves that both times he's just yeah
you really just trying to make money at
any cost and you can I just make I just
make a call this is this is unrelated
but I want to say this as a Jewish
person we always get a bad rap for being
greedy and money-grubbing and all this I
only I don't see goys doing [ __ ] like
this this is this is a white boy from
Ohio I'm just saying the guys people
I've ever known
are not Jewish what okay I think you
said it wrong cuz GUI is not you yeah I
was confused by this
he's a [ __ ] yeah I'm saying he's a [ __ ] or
white dude from Ohio I just want to say
that
my trend that I've noticed is when I see
the grievious people like this sold
their soul do whatever it takes doesn't
care he's not Jewish if he was Jewish
all that comes feel like Oh greeted you
mm-hmm and I'm just saying that because
I get that all the it all the time
there's lots of anti-semitic comments
but I just want to say I want to point
it out thank you you want to point out
that those stereotypes are not true I'm
making an anti stereotype that is a good
point to make thank you very much
how many people are Jewish to the top
ten most wealthy people in the world I
have a feeling there's a lot of Jews
there which makes me feel uncomfortable
but tell me Dan well let's look at the
top ten wealthiest people we just looked
at it last week this is not Jeff Bezos
is not you at Nora's okay Warren Buffett
is Jewish
I know he's not he's that he's altered
oh no way yeah Nebraska oh [ __ ] me so
wait who's Bernard Arnault
I don't know who this guy is Bernard
Oliver might be the only one in the top
well there you go you see everybody's
trying to give the Jews a bad rap we do
not grow I mean the juice I know we're
all very generous I don't understand I
don't I don't get the whole greedy thing
look like if Jay Paul was Jewish every
comment would be like greedy Jew greeted
you greedy Jew but but nobody even
really holds it against him nobody even
calls him greedy he doesn't need to live
with that label all right he should live
with that label forever that he's greedy
is suck Jewish I don't think suck is
Jewish Zuckerberg sounds like a sound
you well let's find out
I don't want him just you disown him
yeah he is
see that's not good we don't like that
[Music]
[Laughter]
so there's two out of ten so that's
that's fit well I mean it's a good
representation but I mean that's 20% of
the list I was expecting worse the
question I guess is how many people
really believe that stereotype I don't
know how many people believe him but
it's something I see a long internet I
don't think is something people say but
I know that like if I
did something like this I would live
with the label greedy forever but Jake
Paul he's done this multiple times he
doesn't live with that label right it
doesn't stick to him like it would stick
to me because you're the greedy Jew he's
greedy he should to own he should get
that label he has done everything what
our what really he's Greek Jake pause on
everything in his power to exploit his
fans sell himself out make as much money
as possible for any at any cost
that's greedy and he needs to own that
label forever you know I know let's call
him gritty greedy greedy greedy JP
greedy
yeah greedy JP greedy Jake you know do
you guys think I make a good point or am
I just being reactionary I know I mean I
I this is obviously coming from a
personal place because you get like you
said I mean I've seen it too obviously
it's like I can't do anything without
being called greedy it's like I can't
even run ads on my podcast to support
this like some what I mean expensive and
complicated operation without being
greedy right but well let's be real I
mean this is we're talking about a tiny
percentage of the people that watch this
well I have I do have I mean you notice
it because it always I don't look
anymore I'm just saying I'm just saying
I'm not it's fine people can say
whatever they want but but you know what
I'm saying is true is that he doesn't
have to live with that label and he
should big time get a pen forever that
says you okay oh not if not a Jew flare
again people people are calling them
worse things that like people are
calling me an idiot or a fool would use
different
it's the greedy thing that it's like
that racially-motivated like when the
greedy Jew like you have to live with
that greedy is worse than all those
things because it's like idiot is like
oh it's not your fault you're an idiot
you're born that way greedy is like
it's it's so ugly and that it's like
you're greedy is just I have to me
that's that's a really bad insult when
used in that way so you feel like it's
associated with the negative connotation
of being Jewish yeah most definitely
okay it went in this in the sense when
they call I mean in some ways that it's
used yet most definitely but what I'm
saying is like it really does apply more
to Jake in this case as we've seen time
and time again that he he really is that
greedy Jew caugh you know what I mean so
let's like what they say about greedy
Jews that's actually Jake so he's a
greedy Jew yes okay but greedy Jews
aren't actually greedy Jews Jake Paul's
the real greedy Jew he's a greedy [ __ ]
he's a he's the greediest jewish boy
okay you know what I mean we talk about
real things here
so that's Jake Paul the greedy Jew
greedy Jew Jake Paul YouTube will love
that
Jake Paul did you yeah GJ j pj g j JP g
j GJ JP greedy Jew jake paul sketchy do
you also want to add a koi cuz he could
have ej j PG greedy guy judy Jay Paul
now you're working keep spinning that GD
JJ actually interestingly Jake Paul got
in trouble unrelated B he was getting
slammed on Twitter yesterday oh I can't
oh did he erase it okay good you you got
an album of it he was actually trending
cuz for this tweet he said remember
anxiety is created by you sometimes you
gotta let life play out everyone remind
yourself to be happy and the answer will
come chill your mind out go for a walk
talk to a friend
I guess people got hung up on the line
remember anxiety is created by you this
one of the lessons that you can expect
to get for your $20 a month that's a
freebie yeah it's a taste of the wisdom
to come
again I think this just I don't think
it's as big of a deal as everyone's
making it out to be I think it just
shows how empathetic and unexperienced
he is in life yeah because he doesn't
really have anxiety problems when you
can say to yourself remember anxiety is
created by you and just go for a walk
kill your mom to a friend yeah I mean
like he just he doesn't have the empathy
to imagine the other people's and right
he might be worse than that
or he's never experienced anything
that's worse than that so what he's
talking about his daily stress right
because he's just so um he's just really
not a wise experienced person he's and
he's never looked outside himself so to
me it's just another it's just another
tweet by a very young overly me an
arrogant person right ruddy Jew greedy
Jewish Jake Paul Thank You Zach by the
way Larry Ellison who is the seventh
richest person in the world and Larry
Page who's the 10th richest person in
the world both also Jewish yeah so
that's four out of ten that's why he
just Jewish last name I don't know I
don't think Paige is a Jewish last name
but I just looked it up his his mother's
a Jew so he's do right four out of ten
that is pretty well well what are you
making that because they're probably all
based out of California in New York and
so these are the places where it's hard
to explain I don't know why I don't know
why it is but greedy duck is a piece of
[ __ ] that's for sure that's a greedy do
Michael Bloomberg is a very greedy
person yes what do we not because I'm
not saying because he's Jewish I'm just
saying yeah how do you know he's greedy
because he has 60 billion dollars you
think you need to be greedy to worth 60
bill uh I think you have to to an extent
be a little bit greedy to have a billion
much of less I mean everybody on this
list has 50 billion dollars or more
yeah I think you do not like to be on
that list and no yes you would
no I would not once you get a taste it's
like you can't stop playing that maybe
did that sound anti-semite no no no
there's self-hating Jews oh then you're
hating on those dollars I'm just kidding
anyway just remember anxieties created
by you and then when people start
trashing him and he was trending on
twitter he clarifies he says what I
meant is that your anxiety can build up
if you let it it doesn't just go away
my never does but there's days when it's
like really bad and then there's days
when it's not as bad so if anxiety
starts to build up there are ways to
help it chill out again you're just
talking about everyday stress I mean
again he's not he doesn't he continues
here are the ways fellows talk to a
friend you look okay well if I don't
have friends
exactly then you're really [ __ ] what
if I don't have legs Jake whatever
Fred's
or legs how rude you good bro and then
he continues to he was actually I'm
surprised that people took this so and
ran with him because he was like anyone
trending like scam wasn't trending yeah
but this one dumb comment he was trying
to be like inspirational and helpful but
it just shows what a dump them here's
but anyway you continues if y'all don't
like my tweet then y'all don't gotta
listen to it but it could help some
people and it helps me with my anxiety
what exactly help what is it that you
said that helps going for a walk over
lunk was feeling like [ __ ] today in
hella anxiety and hella anxiety and
wanted to put a reminder out there to
anyone else who might be having anxiety
today all love he keeps getting clowned
he said everyone climbing my tweet but
it's now spreading more awareness about
anxiety which I didn't even know was a
thing till I was 18 but had it my whole
life and never knew how to deal with it
if you think you have it or want to deal
with it try reading this
Healthline calm had a cope with anxiety
11 simple ways and went to see a doctor
NOAA listicle cool hell flying calm
thank you jack
for the medical advice right then thank
you that video if you want when the kid
I will get back to that and then
actually during this whole tweet storm I
realized that he had blocked me I mean
actually I don't know what I did to
deserve that either the show he's a
friend of the show and it feels bad I
mean you said that in our chat last
night and you were blocked I kind of get
it you do
I haven't wait a while and I haven't
tweeted at him like I don't ever tweet
at him do i that he made some some other
stupid - it could have been kind of a
Logan hasn't blocked me I'm certainly
think that Logan's actually the cool one
Logan was the one that wanted to punch
you in the face when he met you right
yes he hasn't blocked me and he's like
told you that straight up right doesn't
he well what he did when ice well I'll
tell you what happened I was there he
looked at me I see he was what everyone
makes fun of me because I apparently
tell this story all the time I haven't
talked about this in a long time so okay
I don't remember the story I saw Logan
right after me and idubbbz made our
colorblind video I was at a party at
Naches house and Logan Paul notch has on
display like a Rhett a super bright red
sports car some kind of collectible
antique car and I who do I see there
Logan Paul next to this bright red car
so I say you know what instead of this
being awkward and pretending like I
don't see him and pretending like we
don't see each other I'm just gonna go
say hi to him
so I probably had a drink or two in me I
was like you know what let's just go say
hi to Logan and and hopefully bury the
hatchet and I walk over to him and I'm
just I'm just trying to be friendly I
thought he would get a kick out of it
but I said hey Logan what colors that
car
and I genuinely I didn't think that I
was gonna be insulting I just thought I
was I thought he would thought it was
cheeky and laugh and he turned to me and
he goes like this he looks at me and
he's like like that huh and and maybe he
was just like oh I can't believe it's
you I wasn't really scared he was gonna
punch me but he was like yeah man I've
I've daydreamed of what I would say to
you if I ever saw you in person and I
said well here I am what do you want to
say to me and he said I thought about
saying something like your face looks
like you have pubes on or something like
that but you're he goes wait and I he
was humble he said but you're too funny
and quick and you would probably say
something back huh so he was he was um
he did say that so I said you know it's
all good dude uh you know I just want to
say hi oh he wouldn't shake my hand it
was weird I remember cuz we've never
like whenever we would meet anyone in
person it's usually just like everyone
is able to laugh it off and then you
kind of like cool with each other but he
was like the first and probably the only
one that was you could tell that he's
pissed and it was not done yeah I was
surprised but I mean it's first time
ever happened to me I put up my hand and
he would he refused to shake it that's
what happened I I put out my hand said
hey Logan what color's that car when you
turn around I put out my hand and he was
like like no nothing to shake your hand
with a fist so I did find you a tweet
that I think may have caused the block
really it was after the Jake ball
against bowling with cody KO oh wow this
is all like some pretty popular fun
shootin 75,000 I said Jake Paul we need
to discuss cyber bullying also Jake Paul
talks is post Malone whose houses later
stuck up at gunpoint also Jay Paul host
party where girls are drugged also Jake
Paula brainwashed kids to sell demarks
also Jay Paul posting softcore porn for
12 year olds I don't even remember what
sparked this it's daddy he went to court
Cody Co about oh we called him a bully
yeah yeah stupid idiot you had to see
this coming you [ __ ] are you gonna call
me blubber boy you [ __ ] [ __ ] my god
what a douche and that's probably why
but I didn't even tag him I didn't even
tag I just meant like his name it's fine
I'm not defending him by any means but I
understand why so you think he's just
shedding out the haters yeah yeah okay
well he blocked me anyway I think it's
worthy of know it was funny finding that
out though because we had put some links
to his tweets in our show prep guys he
deleted the tweet what the hell I'm like
he's like yeah because when you click it
on your phone it just says this tweets
not available right exactly then I went
on my computer
I'm sure enough you're blocked so there
you have it I thought Twitter narcs on
people just says you're blocked it's
awesome
so if jake has blocked me
congratulations to Jake I've got this
whole like statement on the matter he
says at a rally on Saturday the content
creator along with influential friends
and around 50 teenagers and tween aged
fans some chaperoned by parents that's
so the irony of being chaperoned by a
parent to a to a to a conference that
tells you to drop out of school and pay
him $20 is [ __ ] rich launched the
financial freedom movement FFM in
partnership with Gen Z holdings in the
type of three-way yeah female female
male financial freedom movement hmm it's
a movement a movement it's moving money
from your bank can you already
not wait we didn't do a Papa cold-open
oh [ __ ]
anyway let me continue it's there's
still time in part that's true in
partnership with Gen Z Holdings Inc los
angeles-based brand development group
targeted at millenials and generation Z
audience Hollywood Sports Park a
multi-use outdoor paintball software pal
and BMX venue in Bellflower California
and South East LA County hosted the
event which Paul had posted about on his
Twitter and Instagram accounts the day
before writing that why you guys
giggling so much I mean there was like
30 people there anything I don't know if
it's out yet can you guys see if the
website stuff doesn't work hosted the
event which Paul had post about on
Twitter and Instagram accounts the day
before bringing that education system is
worthless that it teaches kids zero real
life skills for them to secure their own
future on my platform which costs 20
dollars a month
well feature curated content from social
media influencers and business
entrepreneurs including Paul himself the
Golden Boy the most knowledgeable
businessman alive ostensibly it's a
how-to guide on how to monetize in all
my presence stupid
although Paul tell variety is for
anybody who wants insight on how to make
money from their passion subscriptions
also include weekly group video calls
with Paul and guest experts he said FFM
came out of his own experience as a
frustrated student and subsequent
successes on my personality influencer I
was like why are we sitting in class
right now learning the quadratic formula
when we should be learning about taxes
and insurance you should learn how to
tweet a link cuz the link to their
website is sommore I used to be dead
said Paul although he noted the desire
to learn about the latter who didn't
come until after he became a
full-fledged YouTube celebrity he has
almost 20 million subscribers FFM is
according to Paul his chance to use his
position as an influence
for good Wow so this is altruistic to
empower the next generation of digital
entrepreneurs who don't want to
necessarily follow the nine-to-five
daily grind oh did they like not pay for
the bandwidth or whatever oh you're
right it just it just started working
weird let me open it it takes like two
like two minutes to load with join join
FFM calm yeah this website has serious
graphic it just says passion okay
the metadata it just says Jake Paul join
FFM calm it just as Jake Paul they tell
us go to college get a job
let's see what's that Jake Paul you may
want to take a break and come back until
the loads
wow you guys you know upgrade your
hosting you could it's still not fully
loaded just kidding on and dated with
traffic let me look at his channel cuz I
mean that swayed with the link is from
February 16 no but that's two days ago
yeah let me see if he made it in of
YouTube you know he didn't post anything
did he tweet anything I mean I can't
look as I'm blocked oh no it's just all
about the it's weird - there's like
pictures of all the team ten people done
all these people like hate him now
hotline numbers on his Twitter right now
load I can't load it anyway I'll
continue he added that the program does
not have a set curriculum the word
itself evokes a sense of rigidness
people who sign up will learn how to
market themselves the strategies behind
going viral and practical tips on how to
handle business meetings and even
roommates wow dude
Wow which might not which may which
might not be a set of curriculum but
sounds very much at least like an
informal syllabus shut the [ __ ] up these
people at variety wrote this article
just died in a fire on his website it
says you can expect live weekly video
coaching calls with Jake Paul yeah right
no can someone like I'd love dude I
would love to get my hands on one of
those so that's what Jay Paul's up to
that's a race to the bottom
the winds still not fully loaded and the
website is you want me to pay $20 a
month and you don't even have a website
that's functioning I was never even able
to get it open it look at this this
screenshot that I just shared
I can't even load it I mean I can't get
anything you see that yeah okay well
here's the same thing it's white text on
a white background has anyone looked at
this I don't want it
how do I do this without showing our
discord oh if you click on the image it
says open original yeah here's the
website just white and then and then if
you highlight you'll see that they have
texted I oh my god I know that like
that's a black hat SEO method to like
plug keywords and you don't see it but I
don't think that's what they're going
for
yeah it doesn't look like it this looks
like it's actually the info they're
trying to share did what is going on
with your site dude I can't even look
get on there also apparently the $20 a
month that's disc that's 50% off it's oh
oh my god $40 on you before you notice
$40 man that's after the first month
when you can't contact support to cancel
their good luck reaching support the
website doesn't even work yeah exactly
Wow Wow this is like bro this is a not a
good scan at the bro talk to get a
[ __ ] hosting that works $20 a month
down at the bottom of the website there
is a letter to the parents
I guess to reassure them let me see that
look at this a third paragraph in and
it's only gonna get worse once robotics
artificial intelligence and other
technology advancements disrupt the work
first dude dick balls yanking anyway
your this is a total disaster I came to
look at the website I'm out and then
meanwhile speaking of the Paul brothers
race to the bottom Logan Paul has
actually been doing really well on
YouTube and out of curiosity I went over
to his website to his channel to see
what he's been up to and you know look I
don't have a problem with him doing
whatever he wants his views have been
way up he started ripping on material I
don't know when I say ripoff I don't
know but he's doing like david dobrik
style vlogs like really short tons of
jump cuts high-intensity and look at
this thumbnail that's four point five
million views I mean I can't do that
[ __ ] so I just clicked this one because
I know Lana roads like a really famous
porn star I was like Lana Rose so again
you all know what his target demographic
is I mean these are eight to I would say
eight to at most 15 probably more like
twelve and thirteen-year-olds are
watching him in this video this five
minute video you have drinking alcohol
smoking weed almost naked porn stars and
it's not age restricted yet every time I
make no it's not yet every time I make a
podcast here just sitting here for two
hours talking I always am dealing with
the monetization immature ratings demon
and age restrictions it's like what
about what I'm doing for mature my
audience is like college aged mature
people I'm sitting here having a
conversation and earnest so I just again
I don't get it
I don't get why
I I'm afraid to even show you guys the
[ __ ] in here because um because I think
that it will get our whole to our
podcast
demonetised for even showing this [ __ ]
but you'll have to take my word for it
I've been I've been watching some of
those stuff he has like copyrighted
songs in there like you had a Rolling
Stone song in there yeah I think we know
it's not to david dobrik does the same
thing they have some kind of licensing
agreement with whoever owns the
publishing which is which is really cool
I'm jealous I want that I really want
that I mean it's just a matter you just
got pay well I think it has to do with
if I had the guests their agency or
their manager whoever has some kind of
arrangement with whatever label owns all
those tracks mm-hmm and they like give
their channels some kind of green light
so they don't claim their content which
is awesome I wish I could get that
because it seriously menu probably cash
but I don't know what that entails I
don't know mm-hmm if they pay them I
don't know my hunch is that they don't
even pay for it I think that these I
think they probably just realized that
it's good for everybody to play the song
because these kids probably don't know
Rolling Stones and they hear that song
and all of a sudden they care why should
the Khan yeah other oh you muted it that
was so slick yeah they're playing
Rolling Stones here and we didn't list
this song so let's just get past this so
this whole video is just him sitting in
a car with Lana Rose who's apparently
dating his friend for his birthday he's
like this guy has everything so I'm
gonna get him his favorite porn star and
now they're apparently dating and
[ __ ] and let's watch this
conversation me I can't my friend's
girlfriend anymore
I just can't lost a fan she said why is
that
I can't jerk off to my friend's
girlfriend about me and Mike's porn is
that happening we have a sext
you want to know the worst part about
all this I'm lying
I died last night I even lied to Josie
about it he asked me if I watched you
and I was like no Josie you Josie the
conversations that this is tame compared
to what I saw yeah understand how this
is an interest rate but like how am i
how are they clamping down on me it's
like over a course of two hours of
course I'm gonna say [ __ ] that like you
have to use your [ __ ] brain YouTube
I'm here trying to jam it business here
in earnest I'm you know what it's like
user [ __ ] prey and they're serving
this kid this [ __ ] the kids it's getting
tons of views I'm sure it's being
recommended [ __ ] you I'm so angry but
they're like well he bleeped out the it
lived the f-word he jerks off he bleep
down
this girl's wearing thongs yeah porn
stars and the thumbnail in the video
she's wearing lingerie she's in bed she
wears that kid by the way this one when
it got so cringe I actually just shut it
off watch this what do you think of me
like personally like aesthetically I
think it's off it's a race to the bottom
you know it's like it's like yeah of
course you can get views from kids when
you have porn stars and lingerie and all
you're talking about snotty sex stuff
and smoking weed and drinking I jerked
off to your girlfriend bail that turns
me on
yeah you gotta give it to him no I'm
getting served to ads and stuff I mean
you got to give it to him it's genius
they've thought about this so like you
know how we're gonna get views like
let's get people ring and
alanna roads the most famous porn star
in the world get her in here and get her
in lingerie pretend that she's [ __ ]
my friend I mean they're smoking giant
ass [ __ ] joints in this exactly it's
like a huge like 20 gram joint legit I
mean the dudes getting older I can
understand if he doesn't want to make
kids content anymore I mean I you know
cringy and bad but I can understand
dating older years yeah you don't want
to be it well I mean how old is he
23 yeah I mean he just doesn't want to
make content for 12 year olds anymore I
guess I wouldn't want to let's see
yeah he's 24 but uh but I think you're
right about the fact that I'm sure his
audience still like his audience didn't
suddenly shift ooh you know being much
more mature if there was if there was a
college-age person actually watching
Logan Paul it's so cringy can you even
imagine putting that on in college like
how embarrassing maybe some of these
kids grew up with them and now it's been
one year it's been one year who's grown
up
nobody's grown up it's been one year
since the suicide forest or maybe two in
the letter to parents on Jake Paul's
website yeah they're just like we know
that you want the best for your kid and
you have all this money saved up for
college they're like me trying to get
the parent to pay for this and it's so
shameless also the kids have a pitch to
the parents and know they're addressing
the parent here because the kid has
asked for it and now the parent is
reading this right it's like kids show
this to your parents yeah smart he's
thought of it all except how to host it
he's even saying you probably already
have Netflix or Hulu or Amazon Prime so
much though I'm a day anomaly I'm in the
week I spent on Netflix bro and it's
less he's saying this is better because
those don't help the future
dude if you only learn taxes just google
it there's tons of free resources you
know what I mean like though here's
here's mine you want Ethan's business
and school success advice you cannot
teach anybody anything if they have the
actual will and desire to learn and
achieve something they will figure it
out and learn it despite whatever it is
they're up against you just google it
and you can lower the [ __ ] you want you
don't need to pay anybody anything
there's so many great free resource you
won't learn how to pay taxes you want to
learn most the other shitty said taxes
is so [ __ ] easy you just do it once
are just I don't know I mean number that
the message is fine I agree that there's
a lot of stuff that the school could
teach us but Jake Paul is not gonna
teach me anything well I think he's just
tapping into that general consent that
we all have it's like I think really
just the moralist that you know high
school should have like a civics class
where they teach you how to pay bills
and do taxes and get insurance and all
this [ __ ] you said but that shit's
really not that complicated take it from
me as an adult you do it once you figure
it out it's a pain in the ass it's a
chore but it's not that big of a deal
mm-hmm it's just something you do don't
need to pay anyone to learn about it but
that's true of all the business [ __ ] if
ty Lopez and all these gurus yeah
they prey on people who like when you
get really desperate inside you you'll
claw into anything and you'll you look
for answers wherever you see them and
your desperation visual you what you're
looking for is something that will
momentarily satisfy you these things
will take your money it will make you
feel like you've done an action so
you'll feel satisfied but it will
contribute nothing to your long-term
success at all people have anything
you're worth now because you're less
money and less time you know I mean if
people who really are are destined to
succeed are people who look beyond don't
even see any of that [ __ ] what they see
is their goal they're motivated and
they're gonna figure out on their own
how to achieve it it's within them
and nobody else it's that raw
determination and dedication there's
nobody that will teach you anything
along the way the only knowledge that
matters is stuff you learn on your own
through the act of doing things that's
the only knowledge that matters and has
value you can get advice from people and
along the way once its valve validated
through life experience maybe it brings
on new meaning a new weight but if you
haven't done anything
whatever anybody's telling you is
worthless the only knowledge and
experience that's valuable is things
that you go out and do yourself
nobody can pay you do that nobody can
you can't pay anybody nobody can help
you do that you they're gonna do it or
you're not gonna do it and nothing
anybody says it's gonna motivate you is
going to energize you you either just
are gonna do it or you're not that's it
that's how I feel you're just you're
gonna do it or you're not gonna do it
and everybody else who's just trying to
tell you what to do is just scamming you
yeah they're just stealing your money
what dan is that pretty much I agree
thank you knowledge and that implies to
every one of these guys I'm talking Tim
Robbins ty Lopez Jake Paul [ __ ] Oprah
I don't care who it is
nobody anything anybody tells you is
worthless
compared to your own experience of just
trying to do something anything that's
it that's my take are you throwing our
boy Tim Robbins under the bus like that
tomorrow's it [ __ ] weirdo and I like
this
Tony Robbins is a weirdo yeah
so that's Ethan's been in a school of
business and you don't have to pay me
anything for support team Raghav the
upward Tim Robbins man did him dirty
yeah Tim Robb was a good guy I meant
Tony Robbins I don't know if Tim Robbins
the guy he might be a piece of [ __ ] - I
don't good actor good actor I'll give
him that
for sure he's ever been in the pizza
category he is not not been in the key
well that's it then so that's it that's
all I've got
that's it that's the whole shebang we
didn't go in two hours my do ruffle
since we're gonna have like ten edits
well thank you guys so much
today's Tuesday we'll be joined on
Friday by PewDiePie looking forward to
that looking forward to that and so
hopefully you'll join us then on Friday
and until then I hope you have a
fantastic week I hope you have a great
week I hope you're watching the debates
on Wednesday your boy Bloomberg
Bloomberg I'm excited it's gonna be
maker break he's gonna just suck or he's
gonna even if he's okay I feel like
that's enough that's hey you're probably
gonna hate him you think so 810
[Music]